we have yet another little kernel of the
insanity that has been taking place
behind the scenes with regards to the
Donald Trump bathroom dump of documents
an exclusive Rolling Stone article now
reports that Trump demanded quote my
documents back even after his lawyers
told him he would be indicted this this
is just an unbelievable it reminds us of
the disconnect from reality that this
guy lives in look at this last month
Donald Trump's lawyers told him
he was on the cusp of a Federal
indictment in the classified documents
case but the former president still
wanted quote my documents and quote my
boxes back asking some of his lawyers if
he could get them from the federal
government according to a source with
direct knowledge of the matter and two
other people briefed Trump in the middle
of being told you're about to get
arrested was saying can I get my my
documents back I I want to put them back
in the bathroom maybe he didn't say that
uh going back to the article it's one of
many such conversations Trump has had
over the past few months in these
conversations Trump also claimed it was
quote illegal that he could no longer
have the documents that were seized
those materials Trump insisted belong to
quote me
Trump has also asked if there are any
other possible legal Maneuvers or court
filings they could try to accomplish
this that they hadn't thought of yet you
have to remember these are not Trump's
documents these are in a sense our
documents they're classified most of us
don't actually have a right to see them
but they are the government's documents
the government's documents and the
article addresses that Trump has
incorrectly insisted that the highly
classified documents he was hoarding
were quote mine mine Trump has also
mentioned he'll get the documents back
in 2025 because he predicts he'll be
pleasant president again and will then
get unfettered access to the most
sensitive secrets of the government
um this is a reminder
that this is not a character that Trump
is playing Trump really is the
bottomless narcissist that he is
portrayed to be by many who know him and
many in the media Trump really doesn't
understand the things that he has
reported not to understand when Trump
asked about can we nuke a hurricane when
Trump asked about why can't we consider
new nuking Europe would a flu vaccine
work on covid when Trump asks these
things and his Defenders go
he didn't ask it and if he asked it it
was clearly a joke because he knows
everything he clearly doesn't he still
believes that these are his documents
even though they of course are not and
it's a very interesting sort of peak
into the psyche of trump and remember
Trump keeps insisting that there's
nothing criminal related to what he did
these 37 felony accounts he says it's
all governed by the presidential records
act it is not it doesn't even seem he
knows what that means but it is not
governed by the presidential records act
we are talking here about his actions as
a former president we are talking about
his refusal to give the documents back
when asked we were talking about his
direction of lawyers and others to lie
in obfuscate and hide and refuse to give
back we're talking about all of those
different things
and he keeps insisting it's merely an
issue of the presidential records act
it's not he doesn't get it at this point
it's time to just admit he doesn't get
it he keeps talking about the Clinton
sock drawer tapes as if there's any
equivalency there Bill Clinton recorded
his thoughts while he was in office on
audio tapes he was granted permission to
keep them after a review to use them in
order to I don't remember if it was to
write a book or what it was it's not an
even remotely similar situation Trump is
talking about how oh the Espionage is
it's never been used like this the
Espionage was used in this way six times
while Trump was President of the United
States it is not that rare you can be
against how it's written you can be
against certain Provisions or whatever
it is not unique to Trump and yet again
completely disconnected from reality
whether you're a carpenter painter or
just want to be prepared for emergencies
if you need a gas mask or respirator go
to our sponsor safety as many of you
know I'm into emergency preparedness not
crazy prepping but I want to have some
food stored some supplies I've talked
about water and multiple respirators are
part of that because it's just a staple
of being prepared respirator sales have
been way up in recent years natural
disasters wildfires polluted air
chemical plant accidents unrest of
different kinds militarized police all
sorts of different reasons you never
know when a respirator or a gas mask
from parcel safety might come in handy
and it could be when you least expect it
parcel safety respirators are also
perfect for professionals contractors
painters people doing DIY projects at
home all of parcel safety's respirators
come with a one-year manufacturer's
warranty every respirator or gas mask
comes with a filter competitive prices
large discounts for organizations and
outstanding customer service to be
totally honest I've said before I'm
using these for changing baby diapers
people think I'm kidding and then they
come visit me and I really am not it it
actually is very useful to other parents
out there I do recommend it go to
davidpackman.com safety use the code
Pacman for 25 off your first order the
link is down below